[Música]
bom
sabe aquela crise existencial quando
você fica chorando se perguntando o que
você veio fazer nesse mundo quem eu sou
e você não encontra nenhuma resposta a
essa crise
eu nunca tive a minha crise sempre foi
outra sempre foi ter que ter a paciência
valorizar os processos para chegar nesse
lugar
mas de que lugar eu tô falando eu tô
falando desse lugar de um mundo de
cooperação um mundo de parceria de um
paradigma da abundância onde o ser
humano é capaz de expressar empatia por
todas as formas de vida
é desse mundo que eu tô falando então
desde a adolescência mais ou menos eu
fui buscando estratégias onde eu pudesse
me expressar de forma coerente no mundo
tornando no presente aquilo que eu
almejo vê como um futuro pra toda a
nossa humanidade
foi aí que eu comecei a aprender a
plantar abril construir a coletar água
da chuva a usar um banheiro seco um
banheiro compostável e a me relacionar
com as pessoas de modo que a gente
pudesse tomar decisões de forma
participativa e tudo isso só foi
possível porque eu cresci num contato
íntimo com a natureza e sempre no final
do dia era possível contemplar o lindo
pôr do sol do planalto central e quando
a situação estava um pouco mais tensa
mirren energizar numa incrível cachoeira
e foi aí que desde 2005 mais ou menos eu
comecei a atuar junto com outras pessoas
no que a gente chama de educação para
sustentabilidade ou aprendizagens com a
natureza ou abordagem
negativa o nome em si pouco importa aqui
o que importa é que a nossa prática
busca criar um vínculo íntimo entre as
pessoas ea natureza ressignificando
entendimento que a gente tem por
natureza para construir esse mundo do
paradigma da abundância recentemente
amanhã há mais ou menos oito anos a
gente descobrir um caminho muito potente
para gerar esse vínculo e transformar a
educação esse caminho é a produção de
comida e o ato de se alimentar e porque
a comida a gente fala da comida porque é
cozinhar
foi simplesmente revolucionário no nosso
processo evolutivo e foi também peça
chave para a transformação da nossa
cultura
por outro lado quando a gente entra em
contato com as consequências do que a
agricultura convencional faz hoje a
gente pode se assustar um pouco eu vou
apresentar aqui uns dados que talvez não
seja novidade para a maioria de vocês
mas eu gostaria de enfatizar los para a
gente construir esse raciocínio essa
agricultura como a gente conhece hoje é
responsável por 40% do uso da terra 70%
da água disponível é utilizada por essa
agricultura hoje e ela também é
responsável por 30% das emissões de gás
carbônico consequentemente um terço de
toda a terra fértil do planeta
desapareceu nos últimos 40 anos
quando a gente olha para o desmatamento
somado a todos os impactos que a gente
vem criando nos habitats
a gente vê que a terra hoje está vivendo
o seu sexto processo de extinção em
massa
de fato não é a primeira vez que o
planeta se vê nessa situação de uma
extinção em massa mas é a primeira vez
sim que o planeta vive um processo de
são em massa causado por uma das suas
próprias crias
nós os seres humanos mas nós não
queremos ser extintos não é mesmo
eu pelo menos ainda tem muitas
cachoeiras para conhecer por aqui
mas então o que a gente vai fazer
esses são dados do mundo mas eles não
param por aí
é importante destacar que a obesidade é
um dos maiores problemas de saúde
pública do mundo segundo a organização
mundial de saúde
quando a gente vem para o contexto do
brasil
as coisas não são tão diferentes assim
se a obesidade é um problema no mundo
ela também é um problema aqui no brasil
onde mais de 50% da população brasileira
está passando por questões de obesidade
sobrepeso e quando a gente vai para o
contexto das crianças esse número chega
a até 15%
mas voltando a agricultura aqui 70% dos
nossos alimentos são produzidos com
agrotóxico e desde 2009 o brasil é o
maior consumidor de agrotóxicos do mundo
talvez não faça uma relação tão direta
pra vocês mas vocês sabiam que as
crianças brasileiras são as que passam
mais tempo em frente à tv
são em média cinco horas e 35 minutos na
frente da televisão mais tempo do que
elas passam na escola muitas vezes e uma
pesquisa da universidade da virgínia nos
estados unidos mostrou uma relação
direta entre o tempo que essas crianças
passam em frente à tv e à possibilidade
de desenvolver diabetes bom
esses são só alguns fatos indiscutíveis
do que acontece no mundo e no nosso país
hoje
mas eu não vim aqui para falar sobre
problemas
eu vim falar sobre soluções enquanto
tudo isso aí está acontecendo nesse
momento
existem outras coisas que tão bem estão
acontecendo então eu gostaria de fazer
uma pausa
pedi pra vocês respirarem fundo
ajustarem a a postura na cadeira de
cruzar as pernas e entrando em contato
com esse lugar que é o que faz a gente
se levantar todos os dias
busca entrar em contato com essa coisa
que existe e é o que faz a gente
caminhar sempre enquanto você vai
encontrando esse lugar dentro de você eu
vou te fazer uma pergunta e eu gostaria
que você buscar responder de uma forma
muito espontânea com uma ou duas
palavras chave e compartilhar e com seu
vizinho sua vizinha de cadeira
então eu queria que você trouxesse à
tona o que na sua existência é mais
valioso o que na vida é mais valioso pra
você por favor compartilhe
o legal é rapidinho mesmo por acaso
alguém aqui falou família
alguém falou amor saúde autonomia
liberdade
bom essas palavras são um conjunto de
palavras que sempre aparecem
nós chegamos em berg que é o pai da
comunicação não violenta fez uma
pergunta semelhante a essa em todos os
quatro cantos do mundo independente da
sua classe socioeconômica da sua cultura
essas são as palavras que aparecem e ele
entende que essas são necessidades
humanas básicas compartilhadas
eu gosto de dizer que essas palavras são
valores que nos torna uma comunidade
humana
só que tem alguma coisa que não fecha
nessa história porque se agora a pouco
eu estava compartilhando com vocês que a
gente está acabando com a água
disponível destruindo solo etc e tal e
de repente quando a gente olha para o
nosso desejo mais íntimo individualmente
a gente que é amor
a gente quer saúde a gente quer o bem
estar da família
o que é que está acontecendo porque
quando a gente se junta com mais um
o resultado das escolhas que a gente faz
nos distancia daquilo que
individualmente a gente almeja porque
coletivamente
criamos resultados que individualmente
ninguém quer porque que coletivamente
ninguém quer
quando eu li pela primeira vez essa
pergunta do alto charme
me deu até um calor no coração
tipo ufa existem outras pessoas por aí
que estão tentando entender quais são as
causas estruturantes para essa crise
e aí um ato charme vai dizer que a raiz
a raiz para a manifestação desses
sintomas que a gente viu lá no início é
o tripé da desconexão a desconexão entre
eu e eu a desconexão entre eu e o outro
ea desconexão entre eu eo planeta
satish kumar vai dizer que essa
desconexão faz a gente entender a
natureza como mero recurso sendo que na
verdade nós também somos natureza mas a
boa notícia é que não foi sempre assim
que a gente ágil a pesquisadora riéis
levar mostrar por evidências históricas
e arqueológicas que houve sim no nosso
passado distante sociedades pacíficas
igualitárias que se organizavam em torno
da cooperação e do respeito por todos
inclusive pela natureza
quando a gente entra em contato com essa
informação e com a informação de que
todas as nossas células possuem a
memória de toda a história de evolução
da vida
a gente se dá conta que nós já temos em
nós
todas as estratégias para um processo de
re connect são a gente sabe como fazer
a gente só precisa se lembrar
e qual é o primeiro passo para a gente
começar a se recordar sobre isso
o primeiro passo é a observação observar
simplesmente observar dentro e fora o
tempo inteiro
tudo o que acontece sem julgamento só
observa
o exercício que para ser muito simples e
ele é só que o simples não
necessariamente é fácil está à nossa
disposição e aí a gente descobriu um
exercício que pode tornar a observação
mais potente e esse exercício é ir à
floresta
quando eu chego nessa floresta
eu tenho a oportunidade de dar as boas
vindas aos meus incômodos de deixar que
o espaço responda por que eu estou aqui
observar os fenômenos os padrões a
diversidade os infinitos tons de verde
os ciclos a interconexão o fluxo de
energia e à medida que eu vou observando
eu vou criando tanta intimidade ao ponto
de eu me sentir um com o todo porque eu
sou natureza e é nesse processo que a
gente começa a passar por uma mudança de
percepção aquilo que você sempre viu da
mesma forma passa a trazer outras
informações e uma mudança de percepção
gera uma mudança de pensamento que gera
uma mudança de comportamento e aí
refletindo sobre tudo isso a gente
entendeu que para potencializar a
educação e trazer uma mudança de
percepção para esse contexto o caminho
mais potente que a gente descobriu foi
criar a nossa própria floresta
então eu vou compartilhar com vocês
agora como nasce uma floresta bom uma
floresta nasce de uma outra floresta
então a gente vai pra mata para nos
preparar para a nossa intervenção e
coletar as nossas sementes porque a
gente sabe que a qualidade da
intervenção é diretamente relacionada
com a qualidade interna do interventor
eu vou repetir a qualidade da
intervenção é diretamente relacionada
com a qualidade interna do interventor e
assim a gente vai semeando os berços da
vida de forma diversa optando pela
metodologia de um canteiro por pessoa
e nesse processo a gente cuida agente
rega
a gente colhe ea gente torna o invisível
visível porque a gente se surpreende com
o que está debaixo da terra
a gente celebra nossa colheita e escolhe
o que vai fazer com ela porque foi a
gente que plantou essa é a nossa
autonomia e depois a gente distribui os
excedentes e aí finalmente a gente
cozinha cozinha conectado aos aos
elementos e aos alimentos da época da
sazonalidade cozinha e come feliz aquele
cuscuz de milho porque a gente
valoriza ancestralidade e assim a gente
cria a nossa comunidade humana
sustentável e à medida que a gente vai
colhendo essas plantas de ciclos mais
curtos e médios como a mandioca por
exemplo as árvores crescem ea paisagem
se modifica e à chegada um momento muito
especial que é o momento do manejo que é
o momento onde a gente executa e traz à
tona toda a nossa qualidade de presença
é quando a gente tem uma conversa íntima
com a planta para entender qual é o
movimento a ser feito todo mundo
trabalho ninguém ficar parado
cada um na sua melhor performance
contribuindo de forma inteligente para
um sistema maior
concluindo assim o ciclo de clareira
clareira tendo a certeza de que nós
seres humanos
cumprimos o nosso papel no sistema bom
gente é assim que nasce uma floresta e
nasce tão bem
a empatia por todas as formas de vida
a gente passa a falar a linguagem da
natureza que na verdade a gente não se
sabendo só que precisa manter vivo
dentro de nós porque se nós somos
natureza a gente conhece todos esses
padrões
a gente faz parte desses fenômenos a
gente se equivoca ao achar que as
crianças são um único futuro do nosso
planeta
segundo he menina ávila e humberto
maturana
os adultos são o futuro do planeta
porque nós adultos temos em nossas mãos
a oportunidade de transformar as
relações agora e criar o solo fértil
necessário para que as nossas crianças
se desenvolvam em sua plenitude e de
forma integral
por isso cuidemos dos adultos para que
nós adultos sejamos capazes de expressar
ao mundo aquilo que a gente mais deseja
o amor é por isso que eu estou aqui hoje
e trabalhando com plantio e produção de
alimento na educação pra que a gente
possa criar agora o futuro de abundância
que a gente tanto almeja arrow muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]